>> Now, let's get into
some serious stuff
what we wanted to do is
give you a glimpse of
the great work that's been
happening in the social sector.
We have a series of
presentations which are
curated specifically
to give you a context and
the possible opportunity area
of AI implementation.
I would like to invite.
Ms. Shashikala from WWF.
She could come and
share her thoughts.
>> Good afternoon
everyone I'm Shashikala.
I'm from WWF- India,
Worldwide Fund for Nature.
It's an NGO that works for
wildlife conservation.
It started as wildlife
conservation organization
but we are now working
on varied fields.
So, basically, our aim is
to stop the degradation
of natural resources and
man lives in harmony with nature.
So, that's the basic concept
in which WWF works.
We were founded in 1969
and in India this
is our 50th year.
So, we have our offices in I
think more than 20
states in India,
and we have different
project offices as well.
In Karnataka we
started working in
this wetland division
from last five years,
and we have start try
to bring about changes.
We started with like
rural areas more.
So we started in
wetland conservation
in some areas which
are like peri-urban,
not fully urban areas.
But this year, we have
started with urban also.
So, until or unless
we touch urban areas,
it doesn't show much.
So, we have done lot of
work and whenever we do,
we think that
stakeholder participation,
community participation
and all these things
are very important.
But lately, we have got
to know that technology
also helps a lot in
wetland conservation and all the
conservation activities,
like social, whatever social
activities you want to do.
So, technology can play
a very important rule and
we have felt it many
ways, many times.
So, these are the places
where we are working
in Karnataka.
So, one is Madiwala Wetland.
If somebody's from Bangalore,
they might have
visited this place.
It's in BTM layout,
it in South Bangalore.
So, that's a pretty
good wetland to visit.
Then, we have Kokkarebellur down,
so it is on the way to Mysuru.
When you go to Mysuru,
many of you must have
visited Ranganathittu.
Somebody has visited
Ranganathittu?
Yeah. So, Ranganathittu, but
nobody must have
visited Kokkarebellur.
Anybody? Okay. Great. I have
two people who have
visited Kokkarebellur.
So, the best part of
Kokkarebellur is it
is the only community
reserve in Karnataka.
So, what does a
community reserve?
A community reserve
is a place where
the village or the place
which is all protected.
So, the villagers
protected in itself.
So, the birds come
there for nesting.
So, every season, we
see like thousands
of pelicans and printed storks
coming from Southeast Asia.
They come inside
the village and they stay
there for a good two
to three months,
and they give birth to
their offsprings and then
they take them back.
So, that is how it is.
You can see on the nests
like just you,
if you go and stand there and
that's like a beautiful
sight to see.
The people there they are
so used to this that they
will never lit firecrackers
during Diwali,
because they say that it
will scare the birds.
Even the kids there
don't do that,
so that is something which is
like we have to learn from them.
So, that is the way of life,
they will never build
a second story in
their houses because they see in
a second story birds live there.
We don't have to build
our second story.
So, they are all in
sync with nature.
So, that's very important
about Kokkarebellur.
In Kunigal, Kunigal
is one more place
where it is attached to a town,
Kunigal town and Kunigal
don't decorate the sea,
it's so big lake, big wetland.
So, drinking water is supplied
to few of Kunigal place.
Then, we have Bashettihalli
wetland which is
ahead of Bangalore International
Airport in [inaudible] Town.
So there is a [inaudible] park,
it's in [inaudible]
industrial area.
So, it is like a very typical of
a wetland because one side
you have Industries,
one side you have a village.
To bring both of them
together for conservation is
a victim because industry
say that villagers,
they don't understand and they
throw their garbage inside.
Villager will say that they are
discharging their effluent
into the lake.
So, that's a victim.
So, today I'm
just concentrating on
Bashetihalli Wetland.
So, Bashetihalli Wetland if
you see, the major threats,
whenever we start
any intervention in
any place we suppose to do
the situation analysis.
We go around, we
talked to people.
We do all the maps, we see
what all is the major issues.
Then, we got these other threats
which we found like connectivity
with cascade tanks.
So, if you see in Bangalor,
e as well as in Karnataka,
all the wetlands are
cascade systems.
So, if you touch one wetland,
there will be like two wetlands
above, two wetlands below.
So, you have to look at
the wetland series, not
individual wetland.
That's what we did,
we did a lot of surveys
with the local people
as well as the agencies.
There are many agencies.
There are KIADB, there are
KSPCB, Pollution Control Board.
So, we did the survey to find
out what are the channels which
bring water into this wetland
and why the water is
not coming into it.
So, that was a major concern
because this lake,
the major concern
is this wetland.
Water is not coming
into it because
the catchment area
is fully developed.
There is no space for
water to come inside.
So, then we said, "Okay.
If the water is not coming
from the catchment area,
let us at least rejuvenate
the channels which can
bring the water into."
So, when we started doing that,
we did the GIS and we
did all the survey.
We saw the blockages,
like blockages there.
So we took the GIS from
there and we put it in
the map and we saw like how it is
blocked and you have to
desilt it or whatever.
So, again, we use
some technology for
that and we got
a pretty okay map of that.
So, over abstraction of
groundwater because there is
no water in that wetland.
And there is no other major
source of water there.
So, the people around
and the industries,
they are extracting
groundwater and
the groundwater has become
a major business there.
So, whenever you go and
stand there you will see
like 10 tankers going everywhere.
So, it's like common because
industries they can't
live without water.
They need water but
they don't have water.
So, they have to pay a big price
and that's the reason
when we spoke to
many of these industries
they were like please
we will help you in
rejuvenating this wetland.
At least we'll get water
without paying
hefty sum of money.
So, that was something
which we got
it from there and in
Bashettihalli yeah.
So, we never thought
that we will get
to see birds in
such a degraded wetland.
We never thought when we started.
Then we started doing surveys,
and we saw like pelicans
painted stocks and good number
of like around 44 birds.
We have already documented
44 species of birds
in Bashettihalli,
and that's a good thing for
such a degraded wetland.
So, if it has water so it can
have like 100 or 140 birds.
Then solid waste dumping
is one more thing
because we have seen in
everywhere even in
urban area if you see,
whenever we see a land
where no water is there
nothing is there,
people will start making
it a garbage dumping area.
So, that was what was happening.
So, we started with bringing
all the stakeholders
together and forming
a committee and talking to them.
So, in WWF we have a thing
that whenever we leave
a project it should
be sustainable.
It's not like
three years we are there
and we will do A B C
D things then once we leave,
there is nothing for them to do
and people don't know what to do.
So, we make a committee
of all the stakeholders.
It includes local people and
all the agencies and
NGOs if some NGOs
are working around.
So, we bring those people
also and then we
talk to them and
then we'll make
a management action plan.
We need to do A B C D things.
Then the people there will tell,
no I think C is more
important than A.
So, if C is more
important than A,
then let us start with C. So,
that's how we do it.
So, once it's done,
so people take ownership
of that activity.
Like, oh, I was only the person
who asked them to do this and
see this has given results.
So that way, we have started
working there and now we
are trying to join
the cascade of wetlands.
There are like five or
six via cascade wetlands.
So, we are trying to join it
so that water flows into it.
So, we had developed
one more concept of
wetland health assessment.
So, wherever we start working we
will start with wetland
health assessment.
So, this is important
because we have to see
wetlands as holistically
ecological.
So, when we see that we
see the catchment health,
then community perception,
water quality,
and then biota health.
So, community perceptions
many places when we see
there is no use of this,
like now this water body
this is just there.
We don't know if it
is useful or not.
Then we'll tell them okay,
you have a ground bore
well in your house.
Let's see where we
have a bore well.
Okay so, 20 years back
what was they're like no.
So, they'll say 20 years
back we used to
get elected 500 meters of water.
So, now it's 1,200.
So, why this is happening?
Because water is not there.
So, water table is not
getting recharged.
Those things they
were like oh yes,
so this is important
for me to sustain?
So those things come into
community perception.
So we have a survey form which
we go and talk to people
and we tell them,
how do you perceive this wetland?
How would this wetland
is important?
Even if it is important
for you or not.
So, many of them will say, no no.
I don't think there's
nothing in this wetland.
This is just mosquito
breeding ground or whatever.
So, we get different type of
perception of people.
Then Catchment health.
Definitely Catchment health
we go around and
see if it's full
constructed or fully be graded or
there is chance of
bringing it back.
Then water quality.
So, we do it like water analysis.
We have like easy to use kit.
So, we can have like 14 15
parameters at a single go.
So, we take that
parameters like take
that box and we do the 15
parameters and we get the,
we can't get the accurate
in that easy-to-use kit,
but yes, we get the approx.
Like no no, how much
is ammonia content or
how much nitrogen or
dissolved oxygen or
things like that?
So, we'll get an idea
and then biota health
and definitely,
we'll see like birds,
water birds are seen or
the fishes or whatever there.
So, these are few of
the wetland health assessment.
We first train them
the local people and then
they start doing it every month.
So, they will be doing it every
month and we will be just
observing after like
maybe six seven months
once they're trained.
So, they're schools students,
they are like community.
These people like he's from
the forest department.
So, this is Madiwala Lake.
So, forest department
did a training for them.
So, they do the training now.
They do every month and
they will just tell us
that today we are
going to do WHA.
If you're interested you please
come and join. We're like fine.
So, that's how they
have taken over.
So, after doing this we thought
that we should go further
because we are doing
WHA and we are getting
the data like water health
analysis data we are getting,
but we are not able to
use it to the maximum.
We are not able to spread
the awareness like
this wetland is polluted
or we should do
some interventions.
So, those things weer missing.
That's when we thought
of a mobile app.
So, when mobile app was
developed which is basically for
the wetlands and
the water health wetland
health analysis.
So, we will put all
the information into that.
Every month if we're doing
the wetland health assessment,
we will put for lake
A or the wetland A.
This is the parameters or
these are the birds which we saw.
Or these are the problems.
If you as a user if you
have that app and if you
go there and if you see some
illegal something happening
dumping happening,
you can click a picture
and you can put oh,
this is happening in this lake.
So, we can take it or to
the government agency or
the machinery and tell them that
see this is a photograph
and a proof.
So, can you do
something for this?
So, there is a pressure.
So, that's how we wanted
to put the pressure.
So, this was the main,
we thought the benefits of
having this technology
mobile app that's sustainable.
Even if we go from
this project after two or
three or four or five years,
so people will start using it
and and people will
also- this is involving
all the stakeholders.
So, I'll go just with
[inaudible]. So, yeah.
So, different users are
there for this mobile app.
So, there are executives.
They are from the community
and the government stakeholders
who will upload the data
into the mobile app.
Like water analysis report.
So, it is oxygen for month
January, there is February.
March is this. So that way,
they will be uploading.
So, they are one type of users.
The second will be
the general public
who will retrieve information.
If I want to see what
is the dissolved oxygen
for last six months in wetland A.
So, I can just open and just see.
So, that is how I get to know.
Also, the general users,
if I go to a wetland if I see
a bird and I can't
identify that bird,
I can just click the picture
upload it in that and yes,
I'll ask the question.
I can't identify this bird.
So, we have experts,
so we will answer it.
Like this is this bird.
It is found here. All basic
things. So, that this thing.
I'm told we want this to happen,
this is right now not
happening the decision-makers.
So, if we have an issue
like I said dumping
or sewage entering.
So, we want this to go
to the decision maker.
Like BBMP or BWSSB or
whatever the NODA agency which
takes care of this part.
So, we can put pressure
like they should be in
charge and they will say okay
this wetland this problem
is happening.
So, let us go and do
this conservation measures.
So, this is a snapshot of
the mobile application.
So, anybody with Android phone,
it's come only for
Android as of now.
So, this is the Wetland
Health Assessment
like a Physico-
Chemical Parameters.
What are the parameters? Ph is
this much, electric conductivity.
Then this is
the Bird Identification.
So, if I'm a user and I go there,
so it will take the GPS location
and it will put the image.
I'll just click
and add the image;
Which is this tall bird?
So, I will get and then
water footprint calculator.
So, this is inbuilt in
this way, this one.
Just two minutes, not staying.
So, water footprint
calculator is there.
So, I can calculate
my water foot like
more photo footprint,
like carbon footprint we can also
calculate your water footprint
direct, indirect.
So, it has 10 easy questions.
So, after the end
of the questions,
you will get your letter.
It will get red color,
green color,
your water footprint is
okay or you are using
too much water,
and how you can reduce it.
So, that way we have done it.
So, this is what we
want from the technology and
adult prospectus is that,
the first thing is that data
generator it has to
be under one agency.
So, we tried it with KLCDA,
The Karnataka Lake Conservation
and Development Authority which
was an umbrella agency
but now it is dissolved,
due to a lot of
political problems and all.
So, right now it's
Karnataka Tang Conservation
and Development Authority
which has got all those powers,
but there is nobody right
now to give us
any information about that.
Maybe in few months
we'll get something.
This WHA app, which
we have developed,
we want to get
some result out of it,
like some management plan,
some conservation initiative.
Like, if this has A,
B, C, D problems, so,
let us go through
this conservation
like management plan
should be like this.
So, if you can develop
something like that which
will be helpful for everyone,
for the community, as well as for
the wetland and so, yeah.
That's all. Thank you.
>> Thanks, Shashikala, I
think that was interesting.
We're opening up for
couple of questions from
the audience if
anybody is? Yeah sure.
>> I'm trying to understand
what specific ways in which
you think technology would
help because again maximizing
the adoption of the app
itself or sometimes if questions
about the bird
classification question.
>> You're thinking
of in some sense,
making the app much more
functional by adding
some intelligent elements
in the app itself,
which specific parts
can you talk about?
>> Yeah. So, expert,
I don't think because
we have a lot of
experts who are in this.
So, bird identification
and all I think we can,
we have those people,
but we want this externally,
like artificial
intelligence or something,
which can process all the
data and give us like,
now what can be
the management plan for this?
So, we have A, B, C, D things.
So, if we have like too much
of sewerage entering inside.
So, they can suggest like, Okay,
you can have a divert system or
a root zone system to
treat the affluents."
So those things.
Also if they can connect us to
some agencies who are
experts in divert.
So, those things if we can
get all these channelized,
so it will be easier
for these initiatives.
>> I see. So, in a broad sense,
you're saying that there
are some sensors or
some people's feedback
that you get about
the state of a wetland,
and thinking of
what interventions
can be suggested, please.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So, it's like basically
we finally we want to
get a management plan
done for that. Yeah.
>> So, this management
plan sounds very
interesting can you
give an example
of what it might look like?
So, if you get all this data and
supposing the tool were to
come out with a management plan?
What could be an example plan?
>> Okay. So, so managing plan if,
like for example
there is a wetland,
which is like a lot of
sewage is coming inside
like how I said,
and we have got data
about water quality.
So, we are seeing that there
is a continuous inflow
of sewage because of
that ammonia has increased,
and dissolved oxygen
has decreased a lot,
and the lower levels like
depth area there is no oxygen.
So, when the depth level
there is no oxygen,
definitely there
will be no fishes
or no other aquatic
organisms there.
So then, slowly it will die,
this whole ecosystem will die.
So, those things, so after
six months or eight months
we'll see like
a continuous degradation
of those things and birds.
Like maybe bird numbers
decreases, dwindles.
Or people around are not ready to
take ownership of
that particular area,
that particular wetland.
So then, we can think of
some interventions like,
institute treatment,
water treatment.
Like if there is no oxygen
in the lower levels,
so maybe we can have
some floating fountains to
circulate the water and get
oxygen in the lower levels.
Or if the sewage is coming
inside the divert system,
divert system is again
the inflow point you
put some system.
It's like the plants,
which soak the nutrients
from the sewage.
So, those type of
systems we can form.
So, those things are some
of the interventions,
like the management interventions
which can be done. Yeah?
>> Maybe I think it's important.
>> No problem.
>> What is the quality
of GIS data including
the water ways and everything?
Is there existing data
from the government that
something that has to be managed
collected, cloud sourced or what?
>> So, actually maps are
the only thing we get from
the government agencies,
like a revenue map or those maps,
and that also it takes like
their good time to get into that.
Because if you go,
you will say no
this is under this department.
You go and collect it from
the A department
and they will say,
no you got to B department.
So, these all things
but revenue department,
but revenue maps are
the only things which we get.
Those basic revenue maps.
Then GIS, we take Google earth
images like 20 years back,
50 years back, how it was,
and we overlap all those images
and then we come up with this.
So, we have our in-house also or
small department which
does basic things for us.
So, those maps are done by them.
>> All right. Thanks Shashikala.
I think that was
an interesting session.
One takeaway that I would like
to bounce off with you as well.
Studies showed that
there is going to be
17 million drones flying
all over the United
States by 2020.
Only 18 of them will
ever get stuck into
trees because there are
no trees left in
the United States.
So, that's another problem
that we're going to solve.
Jokes apart, but think about it.
If we could fly a drone
over this area and
help her capture
the information that she needs.
Right? That's quite possible
to the greatest level
of detail today by
virtue of technology.
Rallies as a company actually has
implemented a solution where
they fly drones over crops,
to identify the potential
pest that could
infect the crop and thus
give a farmer a headstart,
to saying, "This is the pesticide
that you should apply
to a particular crop.
So, thank you for that.
>> Thank you.